tucked away in an industrial park a
symbol recognized around the world
in the city of lublin in eastern poland
you'll find the red cross's largest base
in the country about two hours from the
border with ukraine
it's the polish government leading plans
to care for ukrainians should they need
to flee west
christian
i want to stress that we are ready to
help those who will be forced to leave
ukraine
the red cross anticipates there could be
as many as 50 000 people crossing into
poland per day should russia invade
the compounding effect could create a
humanitarian crisis on a tremendous
scale
while there's still lots of work to be
done the agency has some items in
holding from 2021 when there was a
crisis on the polish belarussian border
many refugees mostly from the middle
east were misled by officials in belarus
into thinking poland was an open entry
point into europe there are backpacks
and blankets and cots and and some of
these items will actually be repurposed
for any ukrainians who happen to cross
the border
at the first stage there will be
refugees camps organized near the border
refugees will receive a medical and
social aid however those people must be
transported as fast as possible deeply
into poland territory to midland and to
the west because those people will not
be able to live for one week in
gymnasium
relocating those seeking refuge could
help poland more easily absorb the large
numbers of people
a similar strategy was used in 2014 when
fighting first broke out in the east of
ukraine between pro-russian separatists
and ukrainians polish government
officials say they're being guided by
the country's crisis management plans
and those will evolve based on the
situation on the ground
bottom line ukrainians will be welcomed
jeff
crystal gomezing reporting in poland
tonight thanks